c'est dans le quartier de bottier à
nantes que ce week-end l'incroyable
s'est produit qu'une famille sommer et
des flammes cette histoire d'un
sauvetage héroïque à nantes alors qu'une
famille s'est retrouvée prisonnière des
flammes la solidarité d'un quartier a
permis un sauvetage extraordinaires
comment dimanche lorsque les flammes
envahissent un appartement dans lequel
se trouve un couple et leur bébé support
quand le père et l'enfant se met à la
fenêtre pour échapper au pire
alerté par les cris de la famille des
jeunes du quartier décide d'intervenir
impossible de passer par l'immeuble il
décide donc d'accéder à l'appartement
par la façade en réalisant une véritable
chaîne humaine
cette image de ce sauvetage sont tout
simplement hallucinante et ont permis à
l'enfant et ses parents de s'en sortir
indemne grâce à la solidarité de ses
jeunes ce soir les héros de nantes sont
sur notre plateau
je suis très très très heureuse d'avoir
ce sens merci ça kimba merci ismaël
d'être là et merci
kenza ça fait tellement plaisir de voir
ça vraiment merci
alors ça combat merci d'être là vous
avez porté des matelas pour sauver le
bébé c'est ça on a réuni ici c'est sympa
faut le dire c'est ça ccg elle a
participé à la chaîne humaine pour monté
au troisième étage et vous kenza vous
êtes le premier témoin du drame
vous allez mobiliser les jeunes alors
kenza comment vous avez remarqué
lincendie qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
fait mon mari était en bas en train de
bricoler sa voiture et on a entendu des
cris des cris est en cours et il croyait
que c'était une femme qui s'était en
train de se faire battre et non
finalement c'était vraiment la salle j à
commencer donc
et là on a commencé à arriver sur les
lieux mon mari a demandé à une dame qui
criaient en eau de couper son compteur
et de fermer le gaz et alavés peur et
elle pouvait pas descendre parce que
dans l'escalier il y avait trop de fumée
donc on a contacté les services
justement les pompiers ils ont mis du
temps à peut arriver il ya des habitants
qui ont essayé d'appeler on a mobilisé
les jeunes et bravo pour cet acte
d'humanisme ils sont arrivés à faire une
chaîne humaine annonce est parti
chercher aussi un mal classé et du coup
on en arriver à avoir des jeunes devant
et derrière nous avons vous vous ai
compris qu un couple et son bébé était
pris au piège bas au moment justement
quand la dame en ont commencé à crier et
alerter justement que plus de 20 ans
était devant la fenêtre et le papa qui
avait le bébé carrément dans les mains
alors comment vous avez pris la décision
d'intervenir
comment parce que la série qui est une
chaîne humaine incroyable combat comme
vous avez pris la décision d'intervenir
on n'a pas réfléchi à sa descendance
activement ça c'est fait directement on
n'a pas réfléchi
chacun
à contribuer de la manière qu'ils
pourraient donc vous le pouvez moi j'ai
pris les matelas que l'aide il n'est pas
la nasse sur 10 vont voir un match où
j'embrasse annoncé un assaut de sifflets
descendent du match il lui anna soit
avec aussi deux personnes mais comparé
leur carte de séjour ici et lisbonne
chèque et karim n allons les emmener
avec eux aussi que le voilà du coup bas
comme vous voyez sur les vidéos ben ça
pas réfléchir s'enchaîner il avait
paniqué ou pas avait paniqué vous êtes
il faut qu'on les sent franchement on
réfléchissait pas qu'on a foncé ismaël
gens que vous avez vous dit que vous
avez panique et forcément vous aide il
faut qu'il l'avait pas ramené surtout
après quand tu vois un bébé elle est en
train de souffrir elle arrivera pas
d'espérer ans plus tard yves m'en parle
sur v parce que on n'avait pas beaucoup
de choix à part que sort par la fenêtre
alors vous avez participé à la chaîne
humaine à ben oui c'est bah c'était
impressionnant crime city
c'est peut-être ça devait être la
panique ont forcément ou en quelque
façon quoi qu'il en soit on a mobilisé
les jeunes on s'est entraidés et dans un
quartier politique comme ça je sais moi
j'étais très beau sexy et on est
vraiment dans les même si c'est un
quartier prioritaire aujourd'hui moi
j'ai partagé cette vidéo justement avec
océane aussi que je salue puisque c'est
un peu grâce à elle qu'on a eu aussi
cette vidéo pour justement faire valoir
parce que le soir même on a vu que les
pompiers a enfin 20 minutes avait marqué
que les pompiers étaient venus éteindre
le feu mais on n'avait pas dit que
c'étaient les jeunes qui ont pu aussi
voilà bravo c'est ok et bravo aux jeunes
qui ont permis à cette famille d'être
sauvés quand tout le monde a réussi à
sortir
vous avez vu la la la la famille
forcément qu'est ce qui vous a dit ce
que vous allez maintenant elle était en
fait c'est un peu confus tondent était
un peu confus par le drame qui venait de
se passer
ouais après tout un peu confus comme
comme je l'aï dit et ça s'est un peu
éparpillé les confesseurs et 20 pour le
moment voilà on a juste regarder si tu
devais aller bien parce que moi j'ai
avec le matin on l'a réceptionné et là
il a rebondi sur le matelas est
heureusement il a revu de cinq ans mais
ça peut être beaucoup plus dramatique
que ça c'est après les voisins euros ils
ont beaucoup paniqué
c'est vrai que mon conjoint il parlait
avec la dame en disant vraiment étonné
le compteur était né le gaz parce
qu'elle pouvait pas descendre les
vraiment il y avait beaucoup de fumée
dans les escaliers et tout le monde
autour de cet incendie
en les voyant dessus en deux
tous étaient inquiets et on a été
vraiment là dans une action de
solidarité et d'entraidé
je pense que vraiment les jeunes eux
passent comme les pompiers c'est pas la
question mais je pense qu'il sera
l'arrivée du moteur
d'ailleurs les pompiers je vous le dis
ils ont voulu vous rendre hommage c'est
à dire regardez s'est déroulée à vendre
notre arrivée comme vous l'avez souligné
ces jeunes ont réalisé un geste qui
mérite d'être salué un geste héroïque
qui a permis justement de le sauvetage
de cette famille moi je peux je suis
vraiment fier de ce que vous avez fait
ton dès fier dois je m'appuie participé
à l'échelle humaine j'ai un peu trop de
poids j'ai invité ce soir là j'aurais
fait pareil on en rigole maintenant mes
récents puisque vous avez été les moyens
du bord mais vous avez sauvé une famille
et ça c'est bien tout le monde en ait
parlé parce que je vois ça montre aussi
la solidarité
si l'intendance et sa fille c'est très
important de le montrer en ce moment
donc je vous lis on est on est très très
fiers de vous vous êtes mine de rien
c'est vrai que ces jeux vous sent très
très ému ismaël aux siens ah oui surtout
par rapport au bébé et j'ai vu les
larmes des yeux des mamans qui elle
était bien sûr qu'elle était alitée
chaos bas en plus ça à l'appareillage
il-6 mapaq est ce qu'elle va faire de
même des pompiers il était un petit peu
ils ont pas bronchée avec le feu mais
avec le bébé en plus il l'a vu la
panique la revue beaucoup de bruit ben
je pense que
le sauvetage de vie d'un bébé bas je
pense que c'est un devoir avant tout
d'en voir je vais vous dire bravo en
tout cas on voulait absolument que vous
veniez nous dire un mot de ce soir c'est
vrai que tout le monde a parlé de vous
aujourd'hui
ça vous a fait quoi quand on parle de
boue aujourd'hui ça a été bah
franchement
je rassure pas je suis là je regarde que
l'année les chroniqueurs tout le monde
est aujourd'hui je suis avec vous pour
en discuter ça me fait très heureux de
vous avoir encore plus plaisir si ceux
qui étaient là ont pu venir mais dommage
bien sûr je sais alors les allées il ya
deux personnes qui ont participé
activement à ce sauvetage qui s'abattent
aussi qui en loge qui m'arrivait si
voilà là et c'est vrai qu'ils n'ont pas
pu venir parce qu'ils n'ont pas leur
titre de séjour c'est ce que vous nous
avez dit ça et c'est vrai que c'est ces
deux personnes là qui ont vraiment un
parti spectre est intéressant ils sont
trois à trois exactement qui n'ont pas
pu venir parce qu'il faut que ça il est
notre personnel est là ils m'ont dit
voilà ils nous ont dit imaginons qu'on
vienne et que derrière on nous arrête
tout est là justement j'avais seulement
à moi j'avais cette peur là franchement
j'ai passé une heure d'entrevue
si justement les les héros qui s'était
vraiment vraiment c'était vraiment ces
personnes et je pense que voilà comme il
n'avait pas aussi de titre de séjour dès
que les policiers sont arrivés sont
partagés nations et tous les jeunes
justement les en féliciter aussi parce
que c'est un acte de courage ne pas
avoir de papiers en france et puis de
valada les sauver l'acte citoyen honnête
citoyen qui mérite peut-être d'être un
oui en séjour exact vous avez vous avez
reçu un message par exemple d'un membre
du gouvernement n'ont rien vu pendant
quoi rien du tout alors moi j'ai une
association sur le quartier donc qu'elle
a ce sont bien des prêts solidaires et
justement je vais tous les jours dans ce
quartier et du coup je vais vers les
jeunes et je leur propose justement de
venir nous aider au sein de
l'association
et puis justement quand ils nous ont vus
avec mon mari sur place ils sont venus
vraiment dans la solidarité et cesser
les valeurs que je porte aujourd'hui
bravo 15 h 30
elle est réelle valeur